Questions about Rupa Labs? We've had this question from a few people about the Rupa Labs.
One person was disappointed because they ordered labs from Rupa Labs and then they couldn't get a draw for a period of time.
And then they were told that it could take a couple of weeks to get the test back.
Now understand any lab is going to tell you it could take a couple of weeks to get the test back.
If you're getting, it depends on what you're getting done. If you're getting a Syracx test, it could take a couple of weeks to get the test back.
That's a functional medicine test. If you're getting a CBC and a complete metabolic panel, it usually will come back in a couple of days.
Rupa is going to always tell you a couple of weeks so you're not disappointed in bugging them about where the test is going to come back.
When you order through Rupa Labs, you'll have the option to order to find a draw site near you.
So if you go find a draw site near you, you could go with your blood drawn right away.
You'll also have the option, and this is through most labs. If you do any online labs, you'll have the option to get a anonymous to come to your house for a price.
Usually it's about 80 to 150 dollars to have that done.
But then you're subject to, you know, compare your schedule with the flamotomous schedule.
It could be a couple of weeks before the flamotomous can schedule to come to your house to do that draw.
Don't choose that option if you want to get a blood test done quickly.
So if you're looking to get something done quickly, don't choose that option.
And please understand, we're offering this Rupa lab option to people who can't get their labs done through their local doctor.
So this is just an ad on, you know, for people who can't get their labs done, you know, some people don't have a local doctor to work with.
Well, then this is an option. If you have the ability to go through your local doctor or through your oncologist to get labs done, most time they're going to be covered by insurance too.
So it would be best to do it that way.
The Rupa lab option is simply for those people that are like, I don't have a functional doctor anymore. I bird my bridges with my oncologist. He's not going to run anything for me anymore.
Now, how do I get labs done? Well, you know, there's a positive is the negative Rupa labs understand with the Rupa lab option. We make zero pennies on Rupa lab. So it's totally out of our hands.
Rupa makes seven, seven percent. That's how much they make on the labs.
They have to charge $25 per lab to get a doctor's order so they have a local position in the state that you're that you are in that will side off on the labs.
That's that is a huge issue for any practitioner who's doing whose ordering labs for patients that they may talk to online or that are in a, you know, have a practice similar to ours.
If you live in Florida and I'm ordering a lab for you. That's a real great area of legality.
I know I've got license didn't Florida and you're going to get a draw in Florida for a lab.
You really need a Florida license doctor to sign off on that lab that if you want to stay legal, we could get in trouble. You could get in trouble.
So the beauty of Rupa labs is that's how they function. They have doctors at every state that are licensed that can sign off on your lab.
Well, there's a fee for that. It's $25 that's added to each of the lab prices. So when I picked the labs to go into our Rupa lab store.
I picked the labs that we're going to use most often and they are literally the cost from the lab.
And then you pay the $25 and then you pay 7% for the Rupa fee for them to send out the kicked and help coordinate.
You can call them and reschedule and do all that. That's what their fee is. We don't make a penny out of it.
So I understand if it ends up becoming more expensive than if you went to your doctor and you only had to pay a copay.
Well, then the choose that option. It's really for people who don't have that option to choose. So, and then if you have to get something done quickly.
We have one person that they're 200 miles away from any place to get a draw. Well, then you're kind of stop. You're going to have to drive.
You know, there's just there's nothing. There's nobody that's going to be able to service you unless you are able to drive. So it's difficult. I understand, but we're just trying our best to try to give you a service that will help people that are in that situation.